have you thought about life yet after
football like where are you going to be
in five 10 years not much
not much i i you know i'm kind of
focused on what i need to do for now and
i still want to play for a long time so
one day i'll get there i'm not quite
there yet
that was tom brady speaking with e.t
back in 2016. flash forward to 2022 and
the tampa bay buccaneers quarterback is
officially hanging up his football
jersey after 22 years in the nfl and
play professional sports for a long time
it's such a great place we've been so
successful in what we've done
that's right after over two decades
playing in the national football league
the athlete who is widely considered the
greatest quarterback of all time
confirmed recent reports and speculation
about his retirement on instagram
tuesday morning 44 year old brady shared
a lengthy message
reading in part quote this is difficult
for me to write but here it goes i have
loved my nfl career and now it is time
to focus my time and energy on other
things that require my attention
fans have long wondered when brady might
step away from the game
in fact back in 2015 after his wife
gisele bundchen announced her retirement
from modeling et asked brady if he had
any plans to follow suit i wouldn't mind
retiring for some training camps a
really early part of the season where
you got to practice and don't play but
um i don't plan on retiring any time
soon i love what i do i'm very blessed i
don't have any plans to give it up
although she told me 10 years ago when i
met her i said 10 years from now you
know i'm gonna be done playing and we've
been together for almost nine years and
i still say i got ten more years left so
she said the time never changes
so i think i just love it that much
and last week when et chatted with
brady's teammate rob gronkowski he
played coy about the retirement rumors
you tease that you may be back for
another season
will you come back and it's time coming
back with you
oh man well first off you know
you know i can't speak for time he's got
to make his own decision
you know what's best for him and his
family but back to brady in that
announcement the dad of three continues
writing that he has done a lot of
reflecting the past week and asked
himself some difficult questions
ultimately deciding it was time to pass
the torch to the next generation brady
calls his career a quote thrilling ride
full of ups and downs but says it was
the friendships along the way that he'll
hold on to quote i feel like the
luckiest person in the world
as for the future the california native
sums it up with one word exciting
i am going to take it day by day i know
for sure i want to spend a lot of time
giving to others and trying to enrich
other people's lives just as so many
have done for me
[Music]
you